Ted thank you an update now to a story
we first broke at 12 noon a Henderson
school will have armed security on
campus for the remainder of the school
year police investigating a shooting at
Coral Academy Cadence near Warm Springs
and Boulder Highway a news now education
reporter Joshua peguero spoke to parents
who expressed safety concerns
Academy for not canceling classes on
Tuesday and for also not alerting them
sooner about the shooting the teacher
stated if they felt scared and they
wanted to go home they can go home so he
called me to come pick him up Laura
struckman was one of several parents who
didn't believe having her kids in class
was safe why can't we take
[Music]
suspect that we have them in custody and
then maybe send the kids to school
cruel's Cadence campus opened last
August and Brie Cervantes says it seems
administrators don't prioritize safety
and protecting kids the idea of Security
is to put a teacher at each entrance
before school and after school and
that's it there we have no campus
monitors the only time we've ever had
any type of security is obviously like
today Henderson Police arrived to the
campus at 3 40 in the morning for
reports of an unknown person shooting a
building window Coral staff sent an
email to parents notifying them the
campus was shot in random places
shattering three windows that Second
Amendment doesn't overreach other
people's safety it doesn't mean that we
our children are our students our our
family members should they shouldn't
have to be at risk when they go to
school the grocery store Coral Academy
says on Personnel was present at campus
on Tuesday and the campus was also on a
soft lockdown meaning that no visitors
could enter the building reported near
Warm Springs and Boulder Highway Joshua
peguero 8 News Now